[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREA FOEGLER: Hi, and welcome
to Monitoring and Improving
Your Big Data Pipelines.
My name is Andrea Foegler.
I'm a developer on the
Cloud Dataflow team.
And today we're really
going to deep dive
into the tools
and resources that
are available to you to monitor
and investigate and improve
your big data pipelines that
are running in Google Cloud.
We're going to focus primarily
on Cloud Dataflow pipelines,
but the second half of that talk
will be looking at Stackdriver.
And a lot of the
tools and resources
you see there are available
for all of the Google Platform
services.
So a lot of that
information will
be relevant across the board,
regardless of what services
you're working with.
So a quick overview
of our agenda.
We're going to start with
just what are Cloud Dataflow
pipelines.
What kind of things are we
talking about monitoring?
What are they doing?
What's the service doing that
we need to be watching for?
And then we're going to
look at actually building
Cloud Dataflow pipelines.
So why is that relevant
to a monitoring talk?
When we think about
monitoring, a lot
of times what we think
about is that sort
of last operational step
when we have a service
or pipeline that we're running.
And so we've got
everything ready.
We're going to push it out.
And we need to just make sure
that our service is healthy
and everything's
performing as expected.
And if not, then
somebody is getting
alerted or notified
that it's going wrong.
So we're definitely going
to look at that part.
That's an important
part of monitoring.
But a lot of the
tools and resources
we're going to
look at are really
useful much earlier in the
development process than that.
So we're going to talk through
what that process looks like.
So when we get to those
tools and resources,
you can see how to use
them when we're actually
in the middle of that
development process.
Then we're going to go into
the Dataflow UI itself.
There's a lot of great
information there,
and it's all presented
very pipeline centric.
So what I mean by that is
you write your dataflow using
the Dataflow SDK.
And we sort of translate
that into a graph
that you then see
in the Dataflow UI.
And so when you're
navigating in there
and looking at your metrics
and looking at your data,
you're really doing it
through that visualization.
You click, you
navigate by descending
into the hierarchical view.
You are looking at one
step at a time and the way
that you authored that pipeline.
And so then when we move
into the Stackdriver
in our Stackdriver
integration, you're
going to see a very
different view.
And it's going to
very timeline centric
instead of pipeline centric.
And so what you're going to find
is that looking at the behavior
and analyzing what's going
on from that time view
is going to be very different
from what you see when you're
looking at the pipeline view.
Navigation there is also going
to happen via search instead
of clicking through a
graphical interface.
So between these two you have
a very powerful set of tools
depending on what stage
of your development
you're in and what kind of
problem you're looking into
or what kind of data
you're looking for.
So specifically,
diving into what
we're talking about for the
Stackdriver integration,
so Dataflow is integrated
with Stackdriver Logging.
And the main thing you get
from Stackdriver Logging
is when you wrote your pipeline
and you're coding it up,
you start writing debug
messages and whatnot
when you're doing this
on your local computer.
But it's also really
useful for when
things start happening in your
service that you don't expect.
So you log lines about it.
And this is where
you go to find them.
Well, if you have to walk
in there and look for it
and search every
time, that's useful.
I mean, it is your data.
You can go find it.
But one of the great things
you get at by doing that
is the ability to create
metrics based on the log data
that you're putting out.
So you can write
log lines, write
a search for particular
things of interest
that are happening in
the logs, and then you
can create a metric
that actually
lets you track
that, alert on it,
chart how it's
behaving over time,
which is a really powerful
way to monitor your service.
The next thing that
we're going to look at
is kind of the
highlight of this talk.
And this is our new beta
integration of Dataflow metrics
into Stackdriver Monitoring.
So the monitoring data,
the particular metrics
we're exporting, are exactly
the same ones you actually
see in the Dataflow UI.
But from the Dataflow
UI, you get a snapshot.
You get to see just
what's going on right now.
And by exporting
them to Stackdriver,
we get to see a whole
historical view.
And since the
Stackdriver UI isn't
so specific to one
pipeline, one instance,
you can actually compare
things between jobs.
You can compare different stages
of your pipeline to each other.
You can compare different
metrics to each other.
So it's a much different
view of those same metrics
and provides a lot of power in
investigating your pipeline.
And the last thing
we're going to look at
is the GCE metrics
that you can look
at for the instances
that are actually
doing the work on your job.
And so there are a
handful of metrics
that are available
for all GCE instances.
And then if you happen to be a
Stackdriver Premium customer,
then there are
agent-based metrics
which provide a really
rich picture of what's
going on on each instance.
And Dataflow exports those
for all the instances
that are running your pipeline.
And we're going to take
a look at those as well.
So what is a Dataflow
pipeline and what
does the Dataflow service do?
So a Dataflow pipeline
is basically--
it's a graph you construct
using the SDK by saying,
do this operation, then
after that do this operation,
then after that
do this operation.
And you build up a graph.
And then you take
that graph, you
say, hey, Cloud Dataflow
service, execute this graph
for me.
The Dataflow service then
constructs an execution plan
to run that graph.
It then brings up the
juicy instances to run it.
And takes care of, say,
the Dataflow service
may notice that your
job would benefit
from more parallelization.
So then it may actually bring
up more instances for you,
break up the work a little more.
When everything's done,
if you cancel the job,
or if the job just finishes,
or if for some reason
the job fails, it'll shut all
those down and clean everything
up for you.
So this fits into Google Cloud,
kind of like what you see here.
You can actually see
Cloud Dataflow up there
in a couple different places.
And so you have services
in the cloud that
pull your data into the cloud.
Pub/Sub is maybe one of
the most common ones that
gets integrated with Dataflow.
And so Dataflow becomes you're
processing layer for that data
once you get it into the cloud.
So whether you're uploading
files into storage,
or however you got that data, it
then gets pulled into Dataflow.
Dataflow does the processing,
and then pushes it,
usually, out to some
other cloud product,
like maybe a BigQuery table.
But maybe out to
another Pub/Sub topic
where you're going to do
further processing on it.
So one thing to look at
here is that this is not
an uncommon setup.
And there are an awful lot
of little icons on that page.
And so when you think
about monitoring,
you may have a lot of
different services interact.
And they all have
their own quotas.
They all have potential
holdups and timing and issues.
And when you think about
monitoring these things
that becomes a
little bit daunting.
And so when we're talking
about Stackdriver,
one of the fun things that--
I think-- is that
you can kind of use
this unified metric
model to think
about monitoring all these
services at the same time.
And it feels to me
like it brings down
the complexity of
this when you can
think about all these
metrics, get them
all from the same place, use the
same services to analyze them
and notify on them.
So we've kind of looked
at Dataflow pipelines
and the Dataflow service
from the 10,000 foot view.
You've probably heard
about the Apache Beam
Model, the export
of the Dataflow,
making it open source, this
execution model that we've
been using in Dataflow.
And so what that is
is it's a programming
model that the goal is to make
some very complex operations
very easy, and to make
it so that you don't have
to worry about the
parts that you shouldn't
have to worry about.
And you only have to
worry about the core logic
that you're trying to execute.
So like we said that
the GCE instances,
it brings all those up.
All this execution
stuff, you don't
want to think about that when
you're writing your Dataflow
pipelines.
So this is true in Dataflow.
The whole Apache
Beam Model kind of
handles abstracting
away that execution.
It abstracts away
the parallelization.
So a lot of the operations
you want to do that
need to be
parallelized, you don't
want to be responsible for when
to parallelize, when to split.
That's stuff that's all
built into the model.
And then the last thing is
all your reading and writing.
One of the most
complex things you
can do in these big
pipelines is just the RPC,
is to connect to different
things, pull in the data,
make sure it comes in, make
sure you don't lose data,
make sure you don't
duplicate data.
And all that's sort of built
in and hidden in the model too,
so you just get to focus
on the actual logic
that you're trying to do.
These are just a handful of
the common types of operations
that you'll see happening
in Dataflow pipelines.
So event handling.
Handling events by event
time rather than the time
that they get into the service
is a really tricky problem,
and something
everybody wants to do.
So you have clients all over the
place that are uploading data
into your service.
Some of them are going
to go offline sometimes.
Some of them are on
really slow networks.
And so they're arriving all
the time, all over the place.
And you want your service
to process those events
by the time that they were
created, not by the time
they got into your service.
So the Beam Model
kind of abstracts that
into this notion
of event time so
that you can handle
processing them by event time
and not have to worry about
when the data is actually
getting into the service.
Another thing that
you might see is
you have a lot of data coming
in and it's getting corrupted.
And you're not even sure what
to do with it, because who
knows what happens to your data
as it's going across the wire.
And so you want the ability to
say, hey, this is a bad one.
I just want to filter
it out, send it
down some other pipeline,
and let somebody worry
about that thing later.
This embarrassingly
parallel processing
is kind of this
notion of you want
to get aggregate
statistics on your data.
And sometimes you'll want
that by geographical area.
that by user or by session.
And as soon as you start to want
that sort of aggregated data,
all of a sudden you have
this issue of everything
needs to be loaded in memory.
You need to have everything
present at the same time.
And so you need to sort
everything and organize it.
And so being able to
do that without having
to worry about it, so that
all that parallelization
of handling that sorting
and aggregating processing
is all abstracted away
in the model as well.
And as I mentioned,
the I/O connectors.
Because that is just always--
always one of the
challenging things
is the RPCs, your connections,
your reading and your writing,
and make sure that that
stuff is all flowing.
You don't have to worry
about any of that.
So the Dataflow SDK--
then there's an
implementation of this model.
And so it has all these
connectors built in,
does all of this.
And it's designed to run
in the Dataflow service.
And so that actually
comes with a runner
that lets you run locally.
So you can execute
your data flow actually
sitting on your box,
and running on your box,
and accessing your local
machine, your local file
system.
And then you can say, hey, now
I'm ready to launch this thing
and run it in the
Dataflow service.
And so this is what the Dataflow
service is providing you.
All right.
So this process of
developing a pipeline.
So there are three
different phases
you go through when
you're developing.
It's not necessarily like
you move from phase one
to phase to to phase
three and you're done.
But you're sort of
always operating
in one of these three phases.
And so the most
productive one is
your local, your local desktop.
So you're coding on
your local desktop.
If you're writing
in Java, and you've
got IntelliJ up, or Eclipse,
or whatever environment
you usually program in.
And you pull in
the SDK libraries.
And you do your programming.
And you run locally.
And you're pulling
up test data sources
off your local file system.
You're using your debuggers
to see what's going on.
So this is your really
fast iteration time.
It's where you're going to
have the best visibility.
There aren't a whole lot
of tools that we provide,
because you have a lot of tools
on your desktop for doing this.
And then after that,
you have your pipeline
doing what you
generally want it to do.
Then this is where you
move into remote iteration.
So you're going to push
this out to the cloud.
You're going to
run it out there.
You're going to start looking
at your job in the Dataflow UI.
You're going to really focus on
a couple of different things.
One, now you're
actually connecting
to all of these other
services and sources.
Are those connections working?
You're probably running
with a lot more data.
When you run with more data,
is your answer even correct?
Are you're still getting
the correct output?
And lastly, does it scale
like you wanted it to?
And so this is really
where you start
to explore your scalability.
When more data came in, did
it scale like you expected?
If you were to run
with more workers,
did it scale as you expected?
And so you're going to
play around a lot of this.
And this is the time
where all of these tools
are going to come
in, because you can
do a lot of neat comparisons.
If I run with this many
workers, what happened?
When I ran with
this, what happened?
And so we're going to look a
lot at what you'll do there.
When you do see issues
here, you end up
going back to local
development, come up
with a test case that shows
the issue before going in.
Because it's pretty tough to
actually debug in the surface.
We try and give
you a lot of data,
but it's still hard to get the
specifics of what's going on.
And then the last
one is that standard.
What everybody thinks of as
monitoring, where you really
need operational stability.
And so this is where you want
to set up your notifications.
This is where you
want to make sure
that you have everything
you need monitored in a way
that you're like, if
there is a problem,
you're sure there's a problem.
And hopefully you're not paging
everybody every two minutes
because you can't tell the
difference between your data
varying, or there being an
issue in a network somewhere,
and your service
kind of flailing.
And so you need the
right set of metrics
to handle what you need and
make sure everything is caught,
but not letting so
many things that you
can't tell what's going on.
All right.
Can we switch to the demo?
So this is start
of the Dataflow UI.
This is sort of where
you'll come into first.
What you see on
the left-hand side
here are all of the
job names for the jobs.
So I started to clean
this up or think
about moving to something.
And I though, this is
actually kind of useful.
This is sort of
what it looks like.
This is what you
end up looking like.
So you can see on
the left-hand side,
there are a handful
of different names
that are being iterated through.
And those are the
different pipelines
that I'm working with.
If you see on the
right-hand side,
there's a totally unique
identifier over there.
So every time you
execute something,
that one has to change.
That's your unique identifier.
When you're in the
Dataflow UI, you're
really working with
that unique identifier.
When you're in
Stackdriver, you're
actually almost completely
working with the name.
And that's because if you
were going to try and monitor
our chart, it doesn't
do you any good
to use the unique identifier
that happened three weeks ago.
You want to use the
process that you're
running every day at noon
that you called Process Logs.
You want that, not
Tuesday's iteration
that you now have to
go pull up a new chart,
or something for
Wednesday's iteration.
So you can see on the left,
if you name your pipelines--
this is my sell to you that
you should name your pipelines.
I did not early on.
And so then the service
just names one for you.
So you end up with these
unique identifiers,
like you see here on the bottom.
Those are-- they're basically
just a second unique ID.
So you can use them, but
if you provide the names,
you get a lot more
coherency in the data
that you'll look
at in Stackdriver.
So quickly, what you
just get from here,
all of your running jobs
will always float to the top.
So anything that you're
interested in seeing running,
you'll see that up there
without having to go too deep.
And then when
things have failed,
they tend to show up at these
big red exclamation points.
So it's pretty easy
to find those as well.
So like I said,
the Dataflow UI is
going to give you this
very pipeline centric view.
And so what this
is, this is really
just a visual translation
of your pipeline.
And so when you first get
to this page, what you see
is the highest level set of
transforms in your pipeline
being drawn out.
So this one still fairly
large, but not unmanageable.
So what do I mean by the
highest level transforms?
So each of those boxes,
when I say transform,
this is really
just an operation.
And each one of these
boxes is an operation
that you plugged in
when you were writing
your pipeline in the SDK.
So this basically looks like
you create a pipeline object
and you say, apply a transform.
And what happens is every
time you say that you
get a new box in the graph.
And the connection, the line in
between any two of those boxes,
is the data that's being
passed from one operation
into the next one.
And you can provide
the names so that this
makes a little more sense.
If you don't provide one,
it's usually the class name
that you gave.
And so these transforms can
do any number of things.
So the ones at the top of
your graph are usually reads.
They're usually reading
in data from some source.
The ones at the
bottom of your graph
usually are write,
writing data out.
These transforms, there are
ones for flattening your data.
So if you have data coming in
from a lot of different places,
you can merge it all
into one big collection.
There are transforms for
partitioning your data,
if you have data from, say,
different regions that needs
to go to different places.
There are transforms for
doing that parallel sort,
for doing the aggregations,
like we talked about earlier.
And so most of these are--
all those ones I just mentioned,
those are built into the SDK.
And you just apply
them straight up,
and you parameterize
them a little bit.
So you may say, I want you
to filter out some things
if they meet this condition.
So you just pass
in the condition.
So you have all these
transforms to work
with that are pre-built
and just ready
for you to
parameterize a little.
So where those don't work,
there's transform called ParDo,
Parallel Do function.
So that transform
is in there for you.
And that let's you
completely overwrite
the function that's going to
happen on each element that's
in your collection.
So if you want to do
something like, imagine you
have in here a user
visit coming in,
and you need to parse
that URL out of that, then
you would write a little
thing that would take one user
visit log entry in there.
It would parse out the URL.
It would output the URL.
And ultimately, that set
of URLs that came out
would be the input collection
to the next transform.
So that's what we say--
I think I'd call them
functional transforms.
They're the ones that are
actually doing operations.
Then there's kind
of this other class
that I'm going to call
composite transforms.
And they're here purely for
organizational purposes.
They're kind of like for
your organizational sanity.
And then for re-usability
and maintainability as well.
So using them doesn't change
what your pipeline does at all.
Your pipeline still does
exactly the same thing.
But when you're looking
at this, so I'll
show you what happens if
you don't think in terms
of these composite transforms.
So you can tell what the
composite transforms are
because they have that little v.
That's like an expanding arrow.
So this is what this would look
like if you didn't have any--
these don't have much.
But as you get down to
here, what this pipeline
would look like if none of
this stuff was expanded.
So you can start to see--
this one I don't
think does either--
how much harder this
gets to reason about.
There's no logical unit.
Every single
operation that happens
is kind of sitting there.
And if you wanted to
be able to look at it
and go, gosh, is the problem in
where I'm reading on my data,
or where I'm doing the group
by key in the aggregation,
or is the problem
when I'm writing?
And you'd have to go through
and look at every single one
of these boxes.
And some of these things get
to be thousands of boxes big.
You'd have a really tough time.
And so when you start
to organize them,
then that hierarchy can
make it a lot easier
to walk through and
look at your data.
So I'm going to
reload this so that we
close all those back up.
So when you look at any one
of these, you can click on it
and you get-- the
word Step on here
should just be considered
a synonym for transform.
So if you're on a
composite transform,
you are going to see just
the input collection data.
So here's the name of
the input collection--
or sorry, the output.
There's no input
collection on a read.
The output collection.
This is like my
favorite new feature.
When you hover over
the name over here,
do you see it turning
blue on the graph there?
So if all of your
transforms have one output,
this isn't all that exciting.
But some transforms will
have 20, 30 outputs.
And when you're trying
to look at this data,
understand which one
is which, and what
the downstream transform is,
this can be super helpful.
And this just showed up
a couple of weeks ago.
So I love it.
Elements added,
so it's counting.
For every collection
that's in this pipeline,
it's counting how
many elements there.
When you see the
estimated size, it's
estimated because
calculating size
on a lot of different objects
is a really slow operation
and we don't want to shove
that into your pipeline.
So we sample.
We take an average
of the sampling.
And then we multiply it
by the number of elements.
So if your elements are
pretty much all the same size,
that's a really
accurate estimate.
If your objects are all over the
place, your mileage may vary.
The execution time
that you're seeing here
is a roll-up of all
of the transforms that
are in that composite.
So I don't think this
one has anything else.
But like this one, for example.
When you're looking at the data
for this top level transform,
you're basically just seeing
the sum of all the transforms.
So this is where having those
composite transforms, where
you can look over your graph and
kind of see the logical units,
becomes a lot faster and
easier to reason about.
So this one's a ParDo.
So this one's a function
that someone added.
Someone wrote the
function that is
operated on each element
in the input collection.
And so you get a lot of
information over here.
You get to see exactly
what class name is
doing that operation.
So that can make it easy
to go back into your code.
And let's see.
Then your input.
This one actually has
an input collection.
So you can see the
input data as well.
Let's get to an actual group.
So I'm pulling this one up.
You're going to come
across glitches in the UI.
Not entirely uncommon.
This shows a couple of them.
Most of them are
easy to work around.
They're kind of
difficult for us.
So this whole process of running
the execution plan kind of
means your job doesn't
actually run like the graph
that you're seeing
on the screen.
So when we're trying to
map a lot of these metrics
back so that they
look like the pipeline
that you actually
submitted, some things
get a little tough,
like flattens,
for example, which
don't actually
end up anywhere in the process.
So they're always empty.
They never have any
information in them,
because they're not actually
running as flattens.
It doesn't mean anything.
The data is all accounted for.
The time is all accounted for.
We just didn't run
anything called a flatten,
so we don't associate
any data with it.
When you click on
a GroupByKey, you
get a couple of extra
pieces of information
there over on the side.
Most importantly, you
get the bytes read
and the bytes written.
Since most GroupByKeys
are actually
storing your data
on disk until they
get all the data for a
particular key and ready
to process it, this is often
one of the biggest performance
issues that you'll
find in your pipelines.
And so knowing exactly what
that byte count looks like--
if you're kind of
watching your pipeline run
and it usually takes six hours,
and you want to see how many
bytes it's written so far.
So this is updating while
your job is running.
So you can say, well, I know
it usually picks up 54 gig.
And right now it's only
got 22, and it's already
been running the
normal length of time,
so you know at least where
the hold up is happening.
So this one's in here just as
a special GroupByKey thing,
just because that's very
often the performance
issue you're looking into.
I think that's most
of it for step.
Let's go back and look
at the job level data.
So if you click anywhere
that's not on a step,
you get the job data back.
It was also here--
this is what we started when
we brought up this page.
If this job was
not finished, you
would have the option to cancel
your pipeline right here, which
is pretty useful.
All the rest of
this data is just
kind of the definition
of your job.
I think this is fabulous.
So if the job was still
running, and there
were a certain number of
workers still operating,
you would see it here.
And the reason that
that number was there,
you would see that here.
So what this graph is
showing, the blue line
is showing you actually
how many workers
are doing the work for your
job right at that time.
The green one is showing you how
many the Dataflow service would
like to have
working, but may not
be able to, either because it's
hitting quota issues trying
to bring new GCE instances,
or maybe the GCE instances,
for some reason, are just
really slow coming up.
That's the difference
in the time
that you see there is really
just the time it takes
to bring up the GCE instances.
And I have seen
some other reasons.
Right now I can't think
of what any of them are.
But it's a really great
display of exactly how
many workers are working.
And then you can actually
bring that up here
and see some more of
the rationale for what
was happening.
Here, nothing went wrong, and
it happened all very quickly.
But a lot of times
in here, you'll see,
we were trying to do this,
but it didn't happen.
And here's why we
think it didn't happen.
So that's some really neat
data for investigating
what's going on with your job.
These are your resource metrics.
So all the ones
that say Current,
if the job was running,
you would actually see
values there.
All the rest of them are
the cumulative resources
that your job used.
So how much CPU
time did you use?
How much memory did you use?
How much persistent
disk time did you use?
So this is the cumulative
resource usage for your job.
So this will be really neat when
we get over into Stackdriver
and you can both
chart this over time,
but also compare it
between different runs.
These are the custom counters
you can add to the SDK.
So there's a notion
called aggregator
in the current Dataflow SDK.
I think that'll change slightly
with our first implementation
of Apache Beam, but you'll
always have the ability
to define your own metrics.
And that's what these are.
And so here you see
the current value.
You can name them
whatever you want.
And then they're always prefixed
with whatever the transform was
in which you defined them.
So if you wanted to count how
many URLs you saw that ended
in .edu, then you could have
a counter that was your edu
counter.
Every time you saw an element
come through that ended
in .edu, you would then
increment that counter.
And you could see
the value here.
So we do export these
as well to Stackdriver.
So here you can
see the final data,
but in Stackdriver,
you can actually
see how that data
changed over time.
So if you can think
of good metrics
to create and track
how your job is doing,
then you're able to visualize
those, and record and alert
on those as well.
So if you remember those names,
invalid rank and invalid visit,
we'll take a look at those
when we get to Stackdriver.
And here are the
pipeline options.
These are just what you passed
in when you started the job.
But it turns out, if you're
running 10 or 15 different jobs
with 10 or 15 different
set of options,
it can be really
hard to remember
what files this
one ran in, or how
you had configured
the workers, how
you configured the autoscaling.
And so here's where you can
see how you actually ran
that job if you're
trying to figure out
why it did what it did.
Why it didn't autoscale
to some particular number.
So here we have logs.
Before we look, I'm going
to go back here real quick
and go to one of these
ones that failed.
So if there were
errors in the job,
there's a really clear
indicator right here.
It's a yellow triangle
if they're warnings.
Then you get this exclamation
point if they're errors.
So if you click on this guy,
you can see what the error was.
So this was me first putting
together these data flows
and running them here.
And so I got all these errors.
So if I want to know what went
on, I know my dataflow failed.
I can see that.
I can see what it
kind of started.
So this is the first
place you look,
especially if you actually
got on error here.
Sometimes you won't.
But if you do, so
here I can say,
it didn't get the file size.
All right.
Standard stack trace.
Got to go down.
All right, here we go.
So couldn't get the file
size, because it actually
wasn't allowed to access the
file it was trying to read.
So your first step in
debugging, if you have errors,
your quota errors will
usually show up here.
Basic access errors will
So you don't have to go
any further than this
to find these type of errors.
Let's go back to the
one we were looking at.
These have been very
intermittently not showing up.
And I'm not sure why.
I will try one more time here.
If not, we may just not have
the job logs on this one.
And I think we're going to
give up on that because it has
been pretty intermittent today.
So normally, you
would see the logs.
The logs here aren't
terribly interesting
unless there's an error.
Mostly this is just telling
you what the service is doing.
The only interesting
logs here, really,
were the autoscaling
ones, but now you
have that great
graphical representation,
so you don't really need
to look at the logs for it.
Mostly it's just telling
you, we're starting your job.
We brought up some workers.
We're trying to bring
up some more workers.
We're shutting
down your workers.
We're done with your job.
Here's the easiest way to
access the worker logs.
So these are the ones going
to Stackdriver logging.
So we'll jump over there now.
So there are a handful of
logs, the Dataflow SDK.
And some of our code
will export here.
And you'll see those here.
The chance that this is
useful is relatively low,
but they might be.
But this is also where you find
any logging that you added.
So that's what's most
interesting here.
So I happened to add--
oh, I can't spell.
I added a catastrophe log.
So this is the log
that I am emitting,
with just like logger.warn
in the SDK code definition
for this pipeline.
And so here is that.
That's great.
I saw it.
It's not a very interesting log.
But what I can do with this
is this Create Metric button.
Can you see this
up here on the top?
If you click on that,
you get this metric name.
The easiest thing here
is to change this down
just to Dataflow Step, rather
than a particular step,
because you want this to work
for all of your dataflows,
not just that particular one.
And then you give
this guy a name.
So let's see.
Catastro-- and if you want,
you can limit this to--
you see all these
log types here?
Chances are you will
never ever look at them.
The worker logs are the
ones where your logs end up.
So you can limit to
that if you want.
You could also say, I only
want to see the warnings,
because these are all
going to be warnings.
The we create a metric.
Doesn't look like anything
interesting happened.
But we jump over here.
So logs-based metric
have a few different--
or have two different
flavors, I guess.
The first ones here, these
system metrics, these
are always here.
So you have these
automatically without you
having to set anything up.
Which means if you just want
to have an alert that says,
error logs are showing
up in my logs based
on some sort of GCE instance
or a Dataflow job putting them
there, you can create
metrics on that
without having to go
through the process
that I just went through.
Because things like log entry
count are already there,
and you can filter by error.
And I'll show you how to
do that when we get there.
And then the next set are
these user defined ones.
So you can see I already have
user catastrophe down there.
The reason I have that is
so that we can actually
look at data in Stackdriver.
Because it doesn't
retroactively search your logs.
So only if we were creating
new log messages that
matched that metric
would we see the data
show up in Stackdriver.
So I wanted to make
sure we had data there.
So I'm not going to use
the one I just created.
I'm going to use the other
one, which is exactly the same.
I just happened to
create it before I ran
the last few runs of the job.
And so what you can do from
here is create alert for metric.
And this is when we
jump into Stackdriver.
And so this is a logs metric,
which is why it shows up here
under the resource type.
So this is the
same interface you
would see regardless of
what sort of thing you were
trying to set an alert up for.
This is the metric.
We want to see it
against a Dataflow job.
So every time you
see Resource, you're
just going to look for
a Dataflow job on here
when you're looking for anything
you created against something
that was output from Dataflow.
File So anytime this
metric was above,
let's say, three
for five minutes,
you can filter by region.
If you're outputting a similar
type thing for different job
names, you could filter
by different jobs.
We only have it in this one.
And it's only showing
up on the worker logs.
So the way this works, these
can be a little tricky,
because they actually
have to match already
before you can create this.
So you can't say an alert
if this were to ever happen.
You actually have to
have had it happen,
or else these dropdowns
aren't populated,
and then you can't
create the metric.
So that's a little unfortunate.
So you do have to force it
to happen once before you
can easily create a log on it.
But it is kind of
neat, because you get--
as you're building
this metric, this
is what this metric
has looked like.
So since I created it however
long ago I created it,
this is what we have been
seeing with that metric.
So you get to see that, and
it gives you a good idea now,
now that I can see
what it's doing,
I can decide, how do I
want to set my threshold.
Oh, if it goes over
5,000 for more than a
minute, or depending
on how it's behaving.
So you kind of get this
preview at the bottom, set up
your metric.
And then let's see,
save the condition.
There's not really--
here is where you can
add notification information.
So if when this alert
goes off, I think
I set it to go off
if there are two.
So it's clearly going to go
off just like every time there
was a spike there.
You can have it
send you an email.
You can have it do
any number of things.
So this is where you get your
fun alerting functionality.
Nothing else here is
particularly interesting.
I actually already
have one of these.
Oh, I need to delete that guy.
And this will take you to
your Alerting Violations page.
So here, if you're
looking at what
are all the things
potentially going wrong
anywhere in my service, you can
come here and see all of them.
And so you can see
here on the one--
so I tacked on that
2 there on the one
I just created, because
I already had this on.
Because again, I wanted
to have it have already
created some of these alerts
so that you could take
a look without having to wait
the 35 minutes for the job
to run.
So you can see that we have
resolved four of these already.
So if we go into here,
there are no more open,
because it's only looking
back a certain period of time.
And this job isn't
running anymore.
So it's not continuing to alert.
And these alerts
to do self-resolve.
Sometimes that might
not be what you want,
so we've actually
put a lot of effort
into trying to come up with
metric definitions that
do what you want them to do.
I think that'll be
an ongoing game.
So the way that I happened
to set these metrics up,
they're only going to alert
if in the last minute or five
minutes you saw some number
of these errors, which
means as soon as the job
finishes, you're not seeing it
and it does resolve.
So if you do get used to--
if you are going to try and
use these metrics for alerting,
you do have to understand
the Stackdriver model.
Because the Stackdriver
model is really--
it really assumes you're
monitoring a service.
And we're not really a service.
You're running a
pipeline and you're
wanting to monitor your
pipeline execution.
And so you'll find that
thing in Stackdriver
is always kind of
looking backward for now.
If the process
isn't still running,
it doesn't think that
it matters anymore.
And the alerts are
kind of designed
that, well, clearly the
service recovered if you're not
seeing the errors anymore,
because it doesn't understand
that, well, that thing actually
just failed and we still
want to go back and look at it.
So we have some metrics to
make that a little easier.
It does mean you
have to be careful
when you're thinking
about the alerts, though.
So let's see.
So that's alerting.
From here we can
go ahead and look.
So when we did this, we just
set an alert up on a metric.
It's actually a metric, so
we can actually go and look
at that.
And so this tool, this
Metric Explorer up here,
was pretty recently added.
At the point where you're
going, what metrics
do I have available?
What do I want to see?
What can I use to
monitor my job?
What does this data look like?
If I wanted to add alerts on
this, if I wanted to add this
to a dashboard, what
kind of parameters
do I want to put on that?
So that's what this
is really great for,
is just getting a general
sense of what metrics
you have available,
how to access them,
what they look like.
Once you kind of have that,
you won't be in here too much.
But one of the
things we can look
at-- so we know we just created
this metric called catastrophe.
So we can come over
and look at it here.
So this is where
that notion of you're
monitoring a service comes in.
A lot of times, you'll do
this and you'll see nothing.
It still happens.
We're still within an hour of
the last time I ran this job.
So you can see just on
the far left-hand side,
it always comes up as an hour.
So if you ran this job three
hours ago, it's going to say,
I don't have any data.
It does have the data.
You just have to tell the
graph to look back further.
So we're kind of working--
since this is just
getting into Stackdriver
and our model is pretty
different from what they're used
to working with, we're trying
to work with them on how to make
the graphing be a little more
conducive to the
standard Dataflow jobs.
But here you can just click on
six hours and you see the data.
You just have to remember that.
For me it's always a little
bit of a panic when I see that.
Ahh!
No data.
So this is that metric that I
just created a handful of hours
ago to count those logs.
So this is a logging
metric you can see there.
These-- everything here that
starts with Custom Dataflow--
so there have been a
bunch of things that
have run against this project.
Every time a job runs that has
one of these aggregators in it,
you get a custom metric.
And they show up under
this Custom/Dataflow.
And so the ones that we created
were invalid visit and invalid
rank.
Those are the ones we saw
on the right-hand side
when we were looking
at the Dataflow UI.
And so I can look at those too.
So I've run this job six,
seven times since this morning.
This is how these things behave.
Now, I just have a
little counter in there
that basically says,
every time you process
10,000 elements, increment.
So it looks the same
for every single job.
But it's a great
way to say, how do I
look at-- since you can run
everything as the same name
too, you can compare what
it's doing from run to run.
You can look at it historically.
We could pull up a week's worth
of data here if we wanted.
We only have a day's
worth, but we could.
So now we can see these.
We know what it
kind of looks like.
We can decide what we
want to do with that.
A quick scan of what
other data we have here.
So these are the
Dataflow metrics,
these ones that actually
start with Dataflow slash.
So we have those
element count metrics
that we saw on the
right-hand side.
And the estimated byte count.
These are those over time.
Elapsed time is
really just measuring
that the job is still running,
but it gives you an easy way
to alert on things like this job
is taking way longer than I'm
used to it taking.
And I think this was pretty much
every service here publishes
something like an elapsed time.
So you can pull that up.
Now, when we're looking in
here, we have nothing filtering.
So every job I've
run-- remember,
there were a whole bunch of them
on that list page earlier on--
they're all here.
This isn't just the
batch ones that I've run.
So it can get a little confusing
looking at things in this view.
And filtering gets a
little tricky in here.
It'll be fine once we move on.
So you can see,
system lag, which
we'll talk about when we
look at a streaming job.
These are all of the--
oh, there's resource
metrics, so you
can see what your resource
usage is over time.
And then these are those
logging metrics that we have.
So like I said, this
is a good first place
to just play around and
see what you've got.
There's not a whole lot
else to do in here, though.
So for that, there are a
couple of different places
you can enter.
So these are the pages for
the individual resource types.
And so we'll look
at Dataflow ones,
but you can also look
at things like Pub/Sub.
So this is what-- these
are all the topics that
have ever been created.
And one of the jobs, the
streaming job that's running,
actually brings up
a second pipeline
that writes to Pub/Sub,
and then the other one
reads from Pub/Sub.
So you can actually
see that on here.
And if you're
reading from Pub/Sub,
you can see the information
on that subscription.
So it gives you a
way to say, yes,
I'm thinking about
Dataflow, but I can also
look at how all the other
services are operating as well.
So this is the
Pub/Sub dashboard.
Most of the dashboards
look kind of like this.
These are the
incidences that we've
seen of alerts
that you've created
against this sort of thing.
And then the one or two graphs
they think are most useful.
So here's the Dataflow one.
I haven't figured out
the ordering of the jobs
on this page yet, but
they have filtering.
So you don't actually have
to be able to find things.
And they sort.
So when it first comes
up here, your job
may not be where
you expect it to be.
But you can sort by
anything that you'd
like, any of these fields, to
find the job that you want.
Or you can just filter.
So if I'm looking for the
ones called next batch,
they're right here.
So from here, I can see
those incidents again.
So these are the
logging ones, because it
knew that those logs were
created against Dataflow logs.
And so it knew that was a
Dataflow resource that that log
metric was created against.
So when you go to your
Dataflow Resources page,
you're actually going
to see those instances.
So it becomes kind of
a place where you can
find all the data in one place.
So those are all the
alerts that have gone off.
You can also see--
so you can see
how this starts to look a little
odd with the one hour back.
So these are the element counts
for all of the collections
for each run.
And so I can come down here.
And so there's an element
count for each transform,
or collection in
between the transforms.
And so you can see
where those are.
You hover over them down
here and you can see.
So here every run looks the same
because there's no difference
in any of the data.
I'm just running the same job.
But you could see for
each iteration of the job
how did the data differ?
How did the
different collections
show up differently?
And then you can also see-- so
these are the ones that kind
of--
what's the resource
cost of your job?
And so that's what
you see over here.
And so this is each iteration.
So the one thing I did
vary between different runs
of this job are how many
workers I assigned to it.
So you can see the
difference in how much
CPU is used, how
much memory it used
based on the number of
workers that are in there.
So this is what's kind
of the default dashboard.
So you get this automatically
without doing anything.
You run a Dataflow job.
All this stuff shows up.
You click on it
and you get here.
Now, let's say what I was doing
with this particular job is
I wanted to know what
the effect of running
with a bunch of
different workers is.
This kind of lets me see, but
it doesn't make it super obvious
to correlate the
information unless I
remember for sure how many
workers I used on each one.
And so this is
where you can start
to create your own dashboard
that's pulling out the data
that you want.
And so you come over here to
Dashboards here on the left.
And then we can create
our own dashboard.
And then I can add a chart.
I want to add a Dataflow job.
And what I want to look at
is, let's say how many CPUs
it's using at any given time.
And you do have to filter in
here by what job that you want.
This is a global
dashboard at this point.
So if you only want
to look at ones that
were called next batch demo--
I think I have that there.
Again, the one hour.
So this is what the
different number of CPUs
look like during the execution
of several different iterations
of this job.
And then I can add
another chart that shows
let's say the elapsed
time of the job.
I can filter by name.
And again, this is
the name of your job.
And so now you can start to
see how you would build these
up and be able to correlate.
So you can even drag
these lines across.
So I want to say, OK, this
job ended up taking a--
it took 10 and 1/2 minutes.
And I can see over
on the left-hand side
that it used 80 CPU.
These metrics are in
CPU, not in workers.
So if you're using a 2 CPU
worker or a 4 CPU worker,
you're going to see
the CPU count here
and not the worker count.
So when you see 80, I
either ran it with 40 or 20,
depending on whether I had
it configured for 2 or 4.
I'm not sure.
So this is where you get
some really great stuff
for really looking at a bunch
of iterations of your job
and comparing the metrics
as you're going through.
And I think this is
really what you lose out
on the Dataflow UI.
The Dataflow UI really lets you
see the context of the graph,
but doesn't let you see over
time or between jobs very well.
So you get a lot here.
So I'm still-- what
you saw me starting on
was one particular job.
And it's that particular
Dataflow job and just
the Dataflow name, which works.
But you'll find that a lot of
times what you'll actually want
is if I run, let's
say, four dataflows
throughout the day on
every 12 hour increment,
I might call them dash noon,
dash 6, dash midnight, dash 6
AM, or something.
And so I'll have
slightly different ones.
And in that case, you want
to start using groups,
because you don't
necessarily want to think
about them as different things.
You want to alert
on them the same.
You want to look at the data
and compare it all the same.
And so you can create a group.
Groups are-- they're pretty
much prefix searches.
So when you name
your jobs, as long
as you name them with
matching prefixes,
you can turn these
things into a group.
So you just give
this guy a name.
This is my batch one.
Now, the interesting thing here
is that I'm not necessarily
talking about a Dataflow job.
This resource could be anything.
So this is going to make
it really easy for me now
to start building
dashboards that
pull in anything that we happen
to name with this name in it.
Save the group.
Now the group exists.
So now you can basically
use that group just
like the name of a job.
You can filter everything on
that rather than on the name.
So I, in the interest
of time, created one
for the streaming job.
Actually, before we look
at that really quickly,
let's look at the streaming
job in the default.
So the big thing you get out
of here for a streaming job
that you didn't get out of
the batch is that system lag.
So the system lag is
measuring-- this is
kind of a global measurement.
So it's not ideal, but it's
a really good quick measure
of what's hanging
around in your pipeline
and not getting all
the way through it.
So your system lag
is something came in,
and we haven't finished
processing it yet.
So how long is it taking to
get-- is it getting stuck
somewhere?
So this is what's hanging
out in your system
and not making it
all the way through.
So it's a really good
measure of your system
getting stuck or getting slow.
And since your job's
not going to fail
if it's a stream job,
really under any condition,
you need something.
So this is the best
measure we have.
For batch jobs, you can
usually just use the fact
that the job failed, which
there's also a metric for.
The system lag is your
big one when you're
looking at a streaming job.
So that's what
you get over here.
The rest of the metrics
are pretty much the same.
But I wanted you to see
a sample of a dashboard
that you might put together
for monitoring these jobs.
So these are all filtered
down to that group.
And this group is
basically anything
that had next-streaming on it.
So for starters, in this
upper left-hand corner,
you can see this is actually
an agent-based metric.
So for the job.
Unfortunately, these are
only accessible while the job
is still running.
Something we're
trying to work on.
But for the time being,
since these are services
and this is how services
get measured in Stackdriver,
they don't exist anymore
when they don't exist.
So these metrics do disappear.
The streaming job
is still running.
So the agent-based
metrics, the left-hand one,
is telling you what
the memory usage is.
And so you only get
that from the agents.
And so that is the
Stackdriver Premium one.
The middle one, the CPU usage,
you get for any GCE instance.
And you can see how--
let's see if you
pull this guy up.
These are all the
different instances
that are running this,
because we prefix searched.
So we'll have a better
experience here eventually.
But because I said that my group
was defined by next-streaming,
then I'm able to pull in
the CPUs on that group.
I'm able to pull in the Pub/Sub
that actually gets spun up
on that group.
And so I can look at
any type of resource
that I happen to have
connected to this thing,
as long as the naming
conventions work.
So here are all the instances
that are running on that job
and what the CPU
usage looks like.
Here's the system lag,
which again, is probably
the primary thing you're using.
And so you can see
here, the lag is--
so the way that this
generator is operating,
and the way that
the thing that's
pushing all the data onto
Pub/Sub, is it basically
blasts and then backs
off, blasts and backs off.
And so you can see
the lag builds up
when it just can't process
a whole lot of the data.
And then it recovers.
And then the next
blast comes in.
You can tell that because
here's the Pub/Sub subscription.
So you can see how that
aligns with the lag.
And so it's really--
this is the
super-powerful thing that
lets you start to see,
what is the timing
of the different
behaviors, and be
able to use that sort of root
cause the issues that you're
seeing.
So you can see here,
oh, here's where
my Pub/Sub subscription is.
It spiked.
Tons of stuff got put on.
My backlog started
to get pretty bad.
Data fell off.
It recovers and
everything looks good.
Here is that cumulative
metric that's
recording the resource usage.
So if you just want to make
sure your jobs aren't getting
too expensive, you have an
easy way to look at that there.
And then basic
element count, just
depending on whether or not
that's a useful metric here.
You might have your
custom metrics instead
as sort of a gauge of the data.
That's interesting.
I am far more out of
time than I expected,
so I think that I will
stop there with that demo.
So could we go back
to the slides, please?
So just really
quickly to wrap up.
So go and check it out.
So we've just put
this out there.
We've had a few people
working with it.
We're trying to work with it.
But seeing what
people are using,
I happen to think it's
a really great way
to learn about the
Dataflow system.
You can see a lot about what's
going on and investigate.
You just have so much data now.
Well, when's it doing this,
and when's it doing that?
So you can use it to
learn about Dataflow,
but also to really play
around with your own pipelines
and see what's going on.
Ask questions on Stack Overflow.
We watch those, we
answer, and it tells us
what you're looking at.
And so that gives us the
feedback to build and improve
this stuff.
We love to hear from everybody.
And so lastly, we're
talking about Apache Beam,
talking about Dataflow SDK here.
So there are two talks tomorrow.
So if you want to
know more about those,
you should definitely
check those out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]